what's going on guys this is rob and
with the second spider-man trailer
dropping last night and everybody
talking about spider-man today i thought
we might side track from edge of
spider-verse for a quick second don't
worry we'll pick back up with it
tomorrow i promise and we're gonna cover
the story where spider-man meets god i.e
spider-man meets the one above all we
have done videos explaining the one
above all we did a beyond omega level
video on the one above all we never
covered the story where spider-man met
him right which is basically spider-man
back in black it's part of sensational
spider-man which was a really really
cool story but this comes off the heels
of the civil war event for those of you
guys who read that right you guys know
that in that story as a testament to the
fact that peter parker trusted iron
man's position that it's in the best
interest of the superhero community to
register that peter parker revealed his
identity publicly now this is kind of
the unofficial
i guess series of comics that basically
dealt with that right so you had like
civil war where peter parker revealed
his identity you had this comic which is
one that not a lot of people know of
then you go into one more day one moment
in time and brand new day or basically
that some variation of those three right
and as a result of that it kind of gives
us this era where peter parker revealed
his identity and then it was all
basically undone it was kind of the big
reset for spider-man the idea here is
that it initially kind of covers the
nature of spider-man which is to say
peter parker as a young kid who has by
and large over the course of his life
just experienced trials and tribulations
and tragedies right he's lost the people
that are closest to him uncle ben gwen
stacy things like that but he also
endured being bullied at school and
being made fun of and that kind of fit
into the nature of spider-man but it's
also what made him famous right
spider-man is like it's weird when you
think about spider-man right because
it's just spider-man i don't know what
it is i've i've actually talked to a lot
of you guys talked to a lot of fans over
the years at comic cons or when i just
happened to bump into you or something
like that and the topic of spider-man
came up and one of the things that i've
asked is like why do you love spider-man
so much and i've heard a bunch of
different reasons people have said
things like because it could be anybody
under the mask that spider-man was an
escape for a lot of you so you would
read spider-man's comics because you
could imagine yourself being spider-man
right so you get revenge on flash
thompson because he bullied you you get
the girl you have to watch your girl die
when she gets thrown off a bridge just
all that kind of stuff
you know but but for real for true a lot
of people love the character of
spider-man because he's just the
superhero that can't catch a break that
anybody could be him right he's
struggling trying to make his way
figuring out what it means to be a good
guy making mistakes different things
along those lines there's a lot of
relatable aspects to his character and
so of course as we know from the
spider-man mythos along the way he ended
up meeting liz allen now the funny thing
about liz allen is that she's kind of
one of those unsung love interests of
peter parker and in fact she's
overlooked quite a bit when it comes to
virtually any iteration of spider-man
outside of comics and rightfully so i
mean it was one of those things where
they were always kind of missing each
other to a degree the way this worked
was that liz allen she wasn't really
cruel to peter parker but she would kind
of just sort of haze him a little bit
alongside flash thompson she wouldn't go
out of her way to do it but she never
really seemed to concern herself with
like the impact of peter being bullied
by flash now the funny thing about this
is that as time progressed she began to
develop somewhat of a romantic interest
in peter but by that point he was
already seeing betty brandt but during
the time when she was kind of giving him
a hard time not in the most extreme he
actually had a crush on her so by the
time she realized that she had some
measure of interest in him he had
already moved on and so it was one of
those things where for a while peter
never really even considered the idea
that liz allen having an interest in him
was of anything significant now one of
the things that stan lee really tried to
do in the early days of marvel when he
got into amazing spider-man 4 and 5 and
things like that is there was this
attempt to build up this almost kind of
lois lane superman dichotomy there in
the sense that liz allen was actually in
love with spider-man but not knowing
that peter was spider-man basically
rebuked both peter parker and flash
thompson it didn't last all that long
and honestly that's so far back in the
letters pages are something i couldn't
get my hands on that i'm not really even
sure how fans responded to it i don't
know if they loved it or hated it i mean
i have to imagine because a real romance
never really blossomed between peter and
and liz allen that never really happened
and said it was basically peter dating
betty brant for a while him and betty
brant basically split he ended up
getting with gwen stacy she died and
then he got with mary jane watson and
was with her until the events of one
more day so it's one of those things
where like she's just kind of overlooked
in a lot of different ways but the
important thing here is that in this
particular segment it kind of highlights
the idea that in some ways she was there
for him and in some ways she wasn't she
was kind of a person he could talk to
but there wasn't wasn't really a whole
lot of love interest there uh it seemed
like something was blossoming but
nothing really seemed to happen all that
much and then of course peter parker was
bitten by a radioactive spider and
following that and what's really
interesting about this you get this
depiction where peter believed that in
the aftermath of becoming spider-man and
essentially the increase in his life
right the uptick in his life insofar as
being a superhero having enhanced
strength and different things like that
that his life would actually become so
much better that he learned what is in
effect the most popular lesson he would
ever learn which is with great power
must come great responsibility following
the death of uncle ben and that's when
peter's life just kind of in some ways
became worse than it was before he was
spider-man when he wasn't spider-man and
he was just peter his life was pretty
straightforward right he was a kid
trying to make his way through school
getting picked on you know with the hope
of the idea that one the world's not a
terrible place having faith in the idea
that the world is inherently good that
people who do bad things are usually
doing it out of desperation or because
they simply don't know any better or at
the very least having faith in the idea
that those who are villains can be
redeemed uh to becoming spider-man who
just consistently lost things right he
lost gwen stacy he lost uncle ben just
over and over and over again but some of
these losses he sustained were because
of his own actions case in point when
the criminal escaped and peter just let
him go and this guy ultimately ended up
shooting uncle ben and then uncle ben's
death and peter's realization that this
guy was the one who did it culminated in
peter's understanding that he was
basically the one that led to uncle ben
dying that uncle bannon told him time
after time after time with great power
must come great responsibility if you
have the power to help you have the
responsibility to help right just one
facet of what that phrase means peter
had the power to stop that criminal but
he avoided the responsibility of doing
it and the cost was the life of uncle
ben and that was one of the most
significant moments in in peter's life
as most of you guys know that was
important because as he states that was
devastating for peter parker in that the
way it said his uncle's death was only
the first of many trials peter would
endure over the years that of course
there were more deaths his arch enemy
the green goblin his first and some say
truest love gwen stacy these are the
kinds of things that he endured over and
over and over again that as a superhero
whether it's because he found himself in
the in the crosshairs of villains who
were looking to get to him by using his
family or because it was just people in
the wrong place at the wrong time peter
just lost things over and over and over
again and this particular aspect of
peter losing these things will actually
become a very important talking point
but this kind of picks up in the most
recent set of events which is after
having lost uncle ben and then losing
gwen stacy now he's got to contend with
the idea of losing aunt may to the
gunshot that was meant for him after his
identity went public and somebody tried
to kill peter and so with that in mind
he actually ends up just kind of leaving
right taking some time for himself
focusing on all the things that he's
lost over the course of his life harry
osborne who is believed to have been
dead things along those lines and in
turn says like i just need time for
myself and so instead of like going out
i mean obviously peter's pissed but
instead of going out and just beating
criminals within an inch of their life
he ends up just beating up on a trash
can right which is i mean given the kind
of strength he has is the more
responsible thing to do but ultimately
this guy just appears out of nowhere
right just kind of sneaks up on peter
which is something that shouldn't be
able to happen appears out of nowhere
and when peter turns around you know
getting ready to punch this guy this
dude's like i'm not looking for any kind
of trouble and peter's question is like
like who are you and where did you come
from and that's when this guy responds
well i was just walking by and i heard
you pummeling that piece of city
property and i thought you know maybe i
can help so here's the thing let me buy
you a burger and we can talk about
whatever it is that's bothering you and
that's when the situation itself really
seems to dawn on peter parker when the
guy refers to peter by his name now one
of the things to keep in mind because
the world knows peter parker is
spider-man his response is okay whatever
man like it's cool that like you know
who i am but like everybody knows who i
am not a great big huge deal that
doesn't really impress me all that much
and when the guy points to the fact that
peter's hands are all bloody and injured
he's like well it's fine you know
they'll heal themselves and then this
guy heals peter's hands in an instant
and so peter begins to start realizing
something he's like wait a minute wait a
minute you snuck up on me and my
spider-sense didn't go off that's not
possible no one ever the only people
that could sneak up on me without my
spider since going off are like venom
and carnage in like some other symbiote
or maybe somebody like mysterio on a
good day so unless you're one of those
guys and my spider sense would be
telling me that something's wrong
because i'm looking at you in your face
there's got to be something going on who
are you and this guy's response is come
on peter you know who i am and he simply
just emanates this kind of light and
peter comes to the realization that it's
basically god now this is one of those
times when you kind of have to read
between the lines right that somebody
just you know emanating a bright light
doesn't mean anything dazzler can do
that it doesn't mean that dazzler's god
this is one of those situations where
the one above all appears and then just
by virtue of his presence and whatever
powers he uses peter knows that it's him
right it's almost kind of like an
instinctual thing right like i know it's
you right like i know that you're
basically god and that's kind of the
crazy thing is because this is one of 17
times that the one above all has
appeared in marvel comics and appearing
to peter is an even more interesting
thing because what ends up happening is
that once they get to their food the one
above all i mean is not acting the way
you would expect god to act right he's
like i mean you're not you're not eating
your burger where your fries i mean like
what's you got to keep your appetite up
man you got to keep your strength up you
know and so peter's like okay look like
at that point it's just like the
elephant in the room he's like okay we
got to address this man like you know i
know you're like a super busy guy you're
omnipotent or whatever you know and i'm
just this fleck of thing whatever you
know however you want to see me he says
but since we're here since we're
breaking bread he's like maybe you
wouldn't mind telling me if my aunt made
dying is all part of your cosmic scheme
your grand design for my pitiful life
and the response to the one above all is
if i were to tell you that it was what
would you do peter what would your
response be to that and the answer is he
wouldn't do anything because there's
nothing he could do he's quite literally
sitting in the presence of god this is
an omnipotence omniscient indestructible
force and so peter's only response the
only thing he can do is he says i would
beg you to save her right i would tell
you i'd give up anything to save her and
his response is even being spider-man
and peter says in a heartbeat right and
so at that point it's like if you could
rewrite my life's story so that the
spider bites somebody else and i'm
spared all the death that i've
experienced over the years my uncle ben
gwyn her father harry you could do that
right and the one above all just kind of
looks at him for a second and just
basically says i want to take you
somewhere and so what they end up doing
is actually teleporting to robert moses
beach initially peter thinks it's coney
island but the one above all's right
he's like i mean everybody goes to coney
island man come on dude it's like me
taking you to central park right like
everybody goes there i'm not gonna take
you to a tourist trap man and so while
they're here the reason why this beach
was chosen is because this is the place
that peter used to come with his uncle
ben and aunt may when he was a little
kid more so than that as the two of them
are talking the one above all gives this
really really interesting insight into
what it simply means to live because
it's one of the things that you kind of
have to contend with when you read
comics superheroes experience loss and
death and trial and tribulation and
struggle all the time sometimes it's
directly on the nose other times it's
far less direct and far less impactful
but regardless they all experienced that
with iron man it was alcoholism it was
losing people who were important to him
happy hogan dying at one point in time
you know when it comes to somebody like
captain america it was being thrown out
of time so losing everything that was
important to him in his younger days
when you look at all these different
characters who experience these these
losses and these struggles they all cope
with it in their different ways and
that's one of the things that peter asks
here right he's like okay so like is
this all just a test right like because
if i'm being tested then just let me
fail because i have to tell you i'm this
close to breaking and the response of
the one above all is it's not a test it
simply just is and so he says human
suffering is just one of the mysteries
it happens for no good reason and the
people who endure it it doesn't even
always make them better you're one of
the very rare situations peter parker
where you become better because of the
things that you've endured most people
it just makes them worse it just makes
them worse people and that's an accurate
statement right that's a true statement
it just makes them worse people for most
people in this world with the trials and
tribulations they endure the struggles
they face they just usually give up or
they just kind of roll over or they just
become terrible terrible terrible people
right it's real you know it really kind
of depends on the situation but by and
large most people become worse because
of the things that they endure peter
parker has become better and where peter
doubts this right where he's like he's
like there's no way this can possibly be
true when the one above all says it
happens though to everyone it's hard to
explain why it's necessary to someone
who wasn't there when the foundation of
the earth was laid or when the first
walls were built around the oceans peter
asks then what's the point of anything
then if it's all beyond understanding
then what's the point of it and the one
above all says well for starters they
are right like they are simply just part
of the point and what ends up happening
is all these individuals who basically
seem to have no inclination as to why
they're there are all teleported to the
beach and all of these are lives of
people that peter has saved over his
time as spider-man and that's the big
thing that the one above all is pointing
out in terms of how peter being
spider-man has made people's lives
better has made him better as a person
because whenever we endure things right
we as people are things where we really
don't see the value of something unless
it's tangible right we say okay we are
financially successful well how do you
measure that my car my house my credit
cards with ultra high limits the things
that i physically own this is a
testament to how i have become a better
person we very rarely ever look at the
intangible things and use that as a
determination of how we've improved as
human beings right like i was a person
who came from nothing now i have
everything and so i'm i'm a charitable
human being i still treat people with
respect i still act the way that i did
and lived the way that i did back when i
was poor right never losing touch with
your roots we never really look at that
as the standard of how it is that we've
improved or become better in any number
of the ways that that happens over the
course of our lives peter had forgotten
that right the one of the ball says
they're an itsy bitsy teeny-weeny
sampling of all the thousands upon
thousands of people you've saved as
spider-man over the years parents
children grandparents entire families
and so peter's like i mean thousands
really and the one of evolve's like i
mean yeah i'm counting team ups you know
but but yeah like you were involved in
the saving of these people's lives and
so that's when it kind of dawns on peter
for a moment even if it's not
necessarily the all-encompassing answer
he was looking for peter goes as far as
say like you pass through their lives
right you pass in and out of their lives
in minutes or even seconds and you
forget that their lives continue after
you swing away they go back to their
homes their jobs their apartments and
the one above all says you saved all
these people sometimes it was just
swooping in and swooping out and you
never even knew what their faces looked
like whatever the case is these are all
people you've saved and where peter
thanks him the one above all calls it
right he says you're welcome though it
doesn't really answer any of your
questions it doesn't make the suffering
any more bearable does it and the
response of peter is no and that's when
the one above all basically comes out
and tells peter what it is that he wants
to know but doesn't give him the answer
he wants to hear but the one above all
says we all have a purpose peter we all
have a role to play this fortunately or
unfortunately is yours and if it's any
consolation i've asked a lot more from
people much closer to me than you and so
at that moment where peter having this
conversation with god and having this
bit of of a breakdown really just kind
of says i don't want my aunt to die
please don't let her die and the
response to the one above all is simply
have faith peter and that's what's so
interesting about this is that whenever
you think of some being like the one
above all even in the scope of marvel
comics you almost kind of apply this
concept or this desire that you wouldn't
readily get in the real world right like
here in the real world whenever you talk
about a godly entity whichever one you
happen to pray to if you pray to one at
all that it's always one of these things
like they move in mysterious ways or
it's all part of some grand plan and i
think a lot of that is humanity just
trying to develop some method of
understanding about the chaotic nature
of the world well the world's chaos and
there's all kinds of crazy things that
go on and there's good things that
happen to bad people and bad things that
happen to good people and so the only
way to really justify that is to say
well because it's all part of some grand
plan the opposite of that the antithesis
of that is to say because the world just
is and things just happen but what that
does is it basically leans into the
nature of disorder it leans into the
nature of the fact that there is no
order here there is no structure here
it's simply just a globe that spins
around on its own axis that orbits the
sun and things just happen and that with
that kind of disorganization and that
kind of chaos people can't handle it and
so we in turn create order we create
structure whether we attribute that to
some greater deity out there or we
attribute it to something as basic as a
social contract we create that in order
to keep ourselves sane and what would
otherwise be a completely insane world
and so when you look at something like
the one above all in marvel comics
that's what you expect you expect that
same concept to roll over here but what
marvel says is no the one above all does
not have any grand answers it's not like
the one above all comes along and says
well here you go peter here's the answer
to every question you ever wanted to
know and here's what your purpose is in
life and here is why everything that bad
that's ever happened to you has happened
to you he doesn't really get that the
answers he gets from the one above all
is because peter struggling makes people
better sometimes and sometimes it makes
people worse that you as spider-man
despite all the struggles you've endured
have saved the lives of countless people
and that's the best i can give you
there's no grand plan here right i mean
it's like vin diesel said in pitch black
that god is a kid with an ant farm right
he's got no plan whatsoever and that
seems to be the case and this would fit
in pretty neatly with the various
depictions of the marvel cosmic
hierarchy as we've seen it over the
years in marvel comics right al ewing
and all these different guys that in
effect god just set everything in motion
right god's a prime mover and then
whatever happens happens and god just
sits back and watches and that seems to
basically be it and so it's kind of cool
to see peter having this conversation
with god and while he desires more than
anything to get this sort of nuanced
finite understanding of quote unquote
what it all means the response of god is
there is no answer to what it all means
it's simply just it just exists you just
have this life that you live and you do
your best to make the most of it and you
try to help people as often as you can
by understanding the struggles you've
endured and how it can make you better
and then you die one day and that's
basically it you lose people along the
way you gain people along the way right
you lose parents you gain kids it's just
kind of the way this this process and
this cycle works and so it's cool it's a
really really interesting conversation
now one of the things you kind of get
here is a bit of a teaser which never
really seemed to come to fruition that
eventually peter parker mary jane watson
get married they have kids they go on to
have a great life and so peter ends up
you know eventually finding you know
real and true happiness but by and large
this story is great right it's just a
one-off little story here just by itself
but basically peter parker meeting god
so let me know down in the comment
section what you guys think about this
you guys dig it are you guys kind of
like i mean this is stupid let me know
what you guys think
and i will catch you all later
peace
you